aquí tenemos un polinomio de quinto
grado y nos preguntan varias cosas sobre
él lo primero que nos preguntan es lo
siguiente encuentra las raíces reales y
bueno para eso sería muy bueno recordar
que es una raíz y una raíz es lo mismo
que decir vamos a encontrar los ceros
los ceros de este polinomio de quinto
grado es decir son los valores de x que
hacen al polinomio igual a 0 entonces
una raíz es aquella que hace a un
polinomio a un polinomio igual a 0 lo
que vamos a buscar son estos valores de
x las x que satisfacen esto y bueno esas
van a ser las raíces o los ceros y lo
que vamos a buscar ahora son las raíces
reales como aprenderás en un futuro
también puede haber raíces imaginarias o
ceros imaginarios y después nos
preguntan cuántas intersecciones tenemos
con el eje
y bueno como veremos el número de raíces
reales únicas van a ser las
intersecciones que tengamos con el eje x
y como es esto bueno pues qué te parece
si pensamos por aquí en un polinomio
arbitrario déjame poner por aquí algunos
ejes este va a ser mi eje y este va a
ser mi eje x perfecto déjame poner que
son mis ejes y ahora sí quiero que te
fijes en esto imagínate que yo me tomo
por aquí un polinomio arbitrario me voy
a tomar por aquí este polinomio que se
va a ver más o menos así y bueno este es
el eje x entonces si te fijas en este
valor de x entonces qué es lo que sucede
en este punto bueno lo que aquí sucede
es que este valor de x y esto sí lo
vemos con base en la gráfica de esta
función
este valor de x toma el valor de 0 en
vez de x eso quiere decir que entonces
va a ser una raíz y si ésta es una raíz
pues este punto también va a ser una
raíz ya que con este otro valor de x la
función también es igual a 0 y este
también va a ser una raíz porque también
aquí la función es igual a 0 y este
también y es que recuerda si estamos en
el eje x el valor de james o dpd x es 0
por lo tanto en estos puntos la función
sería igual a 0 recuerda esta función es
la función
igual a p
y ojo no necesariamente esta sea la
gráfica de nuestra p de x que tengo aquí
solo estoy dibujando una p de x
arbitraria para que veas lo que está
sucediendo entonces hay algún valor de x
que haga la función igual a cero eso
quiere decir que también ese será un
punto de intersección en nuestra función
y bueno queremos saber cuántas
intersecciones tenemos con el eje x y
como veremos será el mismo número que el
número de raíces reales únicas que
tengamos o el mismo número que el número
de ceros únicos que tengamos en este
polinomio px y por último nos piden
averiguar cuál es la menor intersección
con el eje x y lo calcularemos para este
polinomio particular así que déjenme
darle un poco de espacio voy a quitar
todo esto de aquí porque quiero darle un
poco de espacio y vamos a ver lo
siguiente bien entonces empecemos
queremos resolver para p de x igual a
cero entonces queremos resolver para
x igual a 0
y esto mismo quiere decir que todo esto
lo voy a igualar a cero porque estos p
de x así que queremos resolver esta
ecuación que tengo aquí queremos
encontrar los valores de x que hacen
esto igual a 0 porque si pongo esos
valores en esta función me va a dar que
la función va a ser 0 estás de acuerdo
ok y seguro lo primero que te llama la
atención es que todos estos valores son
divisibles entre x entonces voy a sacar
a x como factor común y me va a quitar
lo siguiente x que multiplica a quien
bueno me quedan x que multiplica a x a
la cuarta potencia aquí más 9 x cuadrada
muy bien menos 2x cuadrada menos 18 y
esto tiene que ser igual a cero y bueno
otra cosa que seguramente te llamó la
atención y de hecho lo acabo de notar al
escribir esto es que tenemos dos
términos de tercer grado justo aquí
acá tenemos dos términos de segundo
grado esto después de sacar como factor
común a x ahora seguramente estás muy
tentado a simplemente sumar estos dos
términos y de hecho sería una manera
completamente legítima para intentar
factorizar esto que tenemos aquí y así
resolver la ecuación pero qué te parece
si en lugar de hacerlo de esa manera
podemos tomar esto como una pista y
quizás podamos factorizar esto por
agrupación recuerda factorizar por
agrupación es separar el término con
grado exponente medium es decir el
término con grado que está entre el
grado más grande y el grado más pequeño
y ver si puedes usar el inverso de la
propiedad distributiva dos veces
entonces veamos si podemos hacer esto se
me ocurre que podemos agrupar estos dos
términos muy bien y podemos agrupar
también estos otros dos términos y sacar
como factor algo interesante y después
tal vez podamos sacar como factor a algo
más a qué me refiero bueno
qué te parece si lo hacemos de estos dos
términos que es lo más que puedo
factorizar bueno primero me queda esta x
de aquí así que déjenme poner la x que
multiplican voy a poner un paréntesis
grande que va a ser todo este paréntesis
que tengo aquí x que multiplica y bueno
de estos dos términos que es lo más que
puedo factorizar se me ocurre que puedo
factorizar a x cuadrada a x cuadrada que
multiplica quién bueno en primer lugar
multiplica a x cuadrada muy bien y en
segundo lugar multiplica a 9 estás de
acuerdo x cuadrada que multiplica a es
cuadrada más 9 es lo mismo que x 49 x
cuadrada muy bien ya esto le vamos a
quitar 2 porque si te das cuenta menos 2
es lo más que puede factorizar de estos
dos de color rosa que tengo aquí déjame
ponerlo menos 2 que va a multiplicar
aquí en bueno primero observa que
multiplica a x cuadrada
y después va a multiplicar a 9 positivo
+ 9 porque observa menos 2 por equis
cuadrada más 9 es lo mismo que menos 2x
cuadrada menos 18 y esto está muy
interesante porque observamos que por
aquí tenemos x cuadradas 9 y por ejemplo
también tenemos x cuadrada más 9 eso me
da una idea de que ahora podemos sacar
como un factor a equis cuadrada más 9
pero bueno esto es igual a 0 y ahora sí
que te parece si sacamos como factor x
cuadrada más 9 es decir vamos a
actualizar este x cuadrada más 9 y este
x cuadrado más 9 y ahora sí que me
quedan x que multiplican y bueno voy a
hacer unos paréntesis también un poco
grandes como por aquí de lujo esto va a
ser igual a cero ya dentro de estos
paréntesis que me quedan bueno me va a
quedar x cuadrada más 9 déjame ponerlo
así
x cuadrada + 9 que multiplica quien
bueno en primer lugar va a multiplicar a
x cuadrada en primer lugar va a
multiplicar a x cuadrada y después
multiplica a menos 2 así que déjame
ponerlo así menos 2 y cerrar este
paréntesis observa x cuadrada más 9
multiplica a x cuadrada y también
multiplica a menos 2 entonces hasta
ahorita hemos sido capaces de reescribir
esta ecuación con la que empezamos como
el producto de x con x cuadrada + 9 con
x cuadrada menos 2 y es más déjame
quitar estos paréntesis que ya no me
sirven de nada lo único que están
haciendo aquí es bueno haciendo que esta
expresión se vea un poco más grande y un
poco más difícil pero realmente estos
paréntesis están demás y de hecho esta
parte de aquí la puedo factorizar como
una diferencia de cuadrados esto de aquí
lo podemos factorizar un poco más déjeme
ponerlo así aquí me va a quedar x
multiplica a x cuadrada más 9 que a su
vez multiplica y lo voy a poner así va a
multiplicar a x menos la raíz cuadrada
de 2 y a su vez esto multiplica lo voy a
poner con este color a x más la raíz
cuadrada de 2 de este de aquí de este de
aquí salieron estos dos lo único que
estoy haciendo es factor izando por
diferencia de cuadrados y bueno claro
esto es igual a cero y ahora sí si tengo
un producto de varias expresiones que es
igual a cero podemos decir que el
producto de estas expresiones será igual
a cero si una o más de estas expresiones
son igual a cero y así podemos resolver
para x si al multiplicar las algunas de
ellas es igual a cero voy a obtener cero
por lo tanto déjame ponerlo así o x
puede ser igual a 0 o x puede ser igual
a 0 y bueno eso se ve muy claramente
tenemos aquí el valor de x igual a cero
todo esto se va a ser cero o déjame
ponerlo con este color o x cuadrada más
9 es igual a 0
déjenme ponerlo así o x cuadrada más 9
es igual a cero de lo que me quedaría
que x cuadrada es igual a menos 9 esto
claro después de restar 9 de ambos lados
y por eso dije que no puede haber una
solución real aquí y observa aquí no
tenemos una solución real es más déjame
escribirlo esto no es una solución real
no
solución real
bueno esto en el caso de que x cuadrada
más 9 sea igual a 0 pero ahora también
tenemos estos dos casos déjame ponerlo
así o x es igual a 0 o x cuadrado más 9
es igual a 0
x menos la raíz de 2 es igual a cero
déjame ponerlo aquí o x menos la raíz de
2 es igual a 0 y ahora si sumo de ambos
lados la raíz cuadrada de 2 me va a
quedar que x es igual a la raíz cuadrada
de 2 positiva la voy a poner así en este
caso cuando x vale la raíz cuadrada de 2
positiva todo este polinomio se hace
cero o bueno también tengo este último
caso
x más la raíz cuadrada de 2 o x más la
raíz cuadrada de 2 es igual a 0 en cuyo
caso podemos restar la raíz de 2 de
ambos lados y me quedaría que x es igual
a menos la raíz cuadrada de 2 el cual
también es un valor real y eso quiere
decir que cuando x toma el valor de la
raíz cuadrada de 2 negativa también este
polinomio se hace cero y entonces ya lo
tenemos ya obtuvimos nuestros ceros x
puede ser igual a cero déjame ponerlo
así x puede ser igual a 0 o x puede ser
igual a la raíz cuadrada de 2 positiva o
x puede ser igual a la raíz cuadrada de
2 negativa ya que p de 0 va a ser cero p
de la raíz cuadrada de 2 también va a
ser cero y pp de menos raíz cuadrada de
2 también va a ser cero entonces nuestro
cero son estos tres y esto nos indica
que tenemos tres intersecciones con el
eje x así que aquí nuestra respuesta es
3 y ahora también nos dicen cuál es
lamenta una intersección con el eje x
bueno pues eso está muy fácil
ya sabemos que la menor intersección con
el eje x es menos la raíz cuadrada de 2
esta de aquí y ahora puedes resolver
esto de aquí de otra manera podrías
tomar esto de aquí arriba y sumar estos
dos términos intermedios y luego
factorizar pero por otra cosa que no sea
agrupación y es más te invito a que lo
hagas y bueno ya para finalizar y solo
para verificar que los ceros realmente
sean puntos de intersección fui a un
gráfica dor fui a wolfram alpha y lo que
hice fue poner este polinomio que
tenemos aquí y obtuve este resultado lo
voy a colocar aquí obtuve esta gráfica
que estoy colocando justo aquí ahora
bien si ves aquí tenemos un polinomio de
quinto grado éste puede tener hasta 50
reales pero ojo si tienes algunos ceros
imaginarios no tendrás cinco ceros
reales por ejemplo en este caso tuvimos
solamente tres ceros reales y esto fue
porque teníamos dos ceros imaginarios de
los cuales hablaremos con más calma en
el futuro
pero lo que sí quiero que sepas es que
siempre vienen en pares conjugados
entonces si no tienes 50 reales 5 raíces
reales entonces la otra posibilidad es
que tengas tres raíces reales y si no
tienes tres raíces reales tampoco la
siguiente posibilidad es que tengas una
raíz real y esto es algo muy interesante
para pensar aquí en este caso puedes ver
que tus raíces reales son tres justo
esta que tenemos aquí esta que tenemos
aquí y esta que tenemos aquí los cuales
corresponden a estos tres valores de
abajo y son los valores de x que hacen
que la función sea igual a 0 y además
observa son los puntos en donde tenemos
nuestras intersecciones con el eje